[Music]
so
thanks tom it's great to be back at ces
we couldn't be more excited for
uncharted and the vision of playstation
productions to bring our stories and
characters
to new forms of entertainment
we just passed the one year mark in the
life cycle of ps5 and we had a
tremendous holiday season
none of this would be possible without
the support of playstation fans and the
invaluable contributions of the
development community and our publishing
partners
under the playstation studios family we
now have a total of 17 studios
and we're looking forward to seeing
these teams shine as they unleash their
creative talents and bring their own
sense of innovation to our first party
content portfolio
innovation on playstation 5 also extends
to the platform experience itself
and in its first year we've already
added new features to the console such
as 3d audio and tv speakers and share
play between ps5 and ps4
this year we're also planning to
introduce a new tournaments feature on
ps5
innovation for us at playstation also
means that we're going to lead the way
with exploring new technology that
unlocks new entertainment experiences
virtual reality is central to that
philosophy nothing elicits emotion quite
like the vr medium
with next generation vr for ps5 it's our
vision to provide the ultimate
entertainment experiences to players
today i'm thrilled to announce the
official names for our next gen vr
system
playstation vr2
and our next gen controllers will be
called
playstation vr2 sense controllers
playstation vr2 will introduce a new
generation of vr games that enable
players to feel a greater sense of
presence and become more immersed within
their game worlds once they put on the
headset and wield the controllers
playstation vr2 will bring together the
power of technology with the creativity
of developers for gamers
that means experiences that can evoke a
whole range of emotions
playstation vr2 taps into the latest
technology to deliver a truly next-gen
experience that brings the player closer
to the gameplay experience
we've developed new sensory features
enhanced controls and tracking
and upgraded visual fidelity
for example with eye tracking you'll be
able to interact more intuitively as
your character while allowing for
improved social expression
the headset also has feedback
so players will feel subtle responsive
vibrations that heighten the sensations
of their in-game actions
visually playstation vr2 will offer a
best-in-class experience
with 4k hdr
foveated rendering and 110 degree field
of view
all of this is on top of the new
playstation vr2 sense controllers
which enable players to feel and
interact with games in a much more
visceral way
we're also excited to announce that one
of the biggest exclusive franchises on
playstation will be coming to
playstation vr2
horizon call of the mountain from
guerrilla games and fire sprite games
this is an original game built for
playstation vr2 that will take place
deeper into the world of verizon
let's take an early look at horizon call
of the mountain
hi everyone i'm jamert von bake i'm one
of the studio directors at gorilla
everyone at our studio is working to put
the last finishing touches on horizon
forbidden west as we get ready for
launch we're all very excited and can't
wait to get the game into your hands on
the 18th of february it's only a few
more weeks
now as you join eloy on her journey into
the forbidden west it's great to know
that this is not the final frontier of
the world of horizon
in fact it's only the beginning
our teams have also been working on a
brand new game set in the world of
horizon which we are very proud to
announce
and so today we like to tell you that
we're creating a unique new horizon
experience one that has been built from
the ground up for playstation's next-gen
vr hardware
it's been designed to push gameplay
technology and hardware innovation
and it truly shows what's possible with
the hardware's best-in-class visual
experience and brand new controllers
allowing you to interact and feel
immersed in the world of horizon in a
whole new way
now please enjoy this glimpse into our
new adventure
welcome
to horizon call of the mountain
it's headed towards us
[Music]
in 2020 sony interactive entertainment
jointly acquired
evil
the world's largest fighting game
competition alongside with a partner rts
while we look forward
building on the momentum in the field of
esports
through evo in 2022
we are also working to create new value
and new experiences
for the